thank you jab and totally in tune with
the conference i'm going to talk about
the importance of
data and the value of it
talking a little bit more about data
this time than
than sharing even though using shared
data in your
mt
system is imminently important
all right so the the product i'm mostly
uh i'm mostly involved in in is
microsoft translator so i'm going to
tell you just a little bit about
about what it is a little bit of the
technical background and then the
drivers of
coverage language coverage and quality
which as you guessed is data
all right so microsoft translator is
integrated in a number of uh of
microsoft products and you may not even
really realize that you are using uh
this
this product
uh when you when you say translate with
with bing or translate with live search
within your internet explorer
application that's what you're using
if you're using office
any any recent version of it you have a
pretty well done
integration of translation services
similar to
to a browser you can hover over any text
and it will give it
give it to you in your language or any
language you choose you
use it with windows live messenger you
can have a multilingual
chat there you just invite
our bot into your conversation it will
simultaneously translate everything you
say or your partner say you can use it
with being fairly fairly common
integration in search engines you get a
result in a foreign language and you are
able to translate it right there
in addition there's a free api that
that um if you're running a localization
tool uh or if you write your own
application you can use it uh we think
it's a very rich and interesting uh api
so if you haven't looked at it may be a
good idea to do that it's integrated in
a number of
tms systems a quick look at the
technology
our system is a statistical mt system
i put it together here in a
in a very simple
or simplified uh
diagram
uh here on the left side you use a lot
of data right that's where where data
comes in
obviously microsoft itself trains on
on its own data that it that it produces
we are a
an active member of the taos data
association and make use of the data
that that it provides
we use all that data to train
statistical models these models are
algorithms that
they produce probabilities
well typically a list of answers and a
probability associated with it you use
lots of these models and combine all the
all the answers of the statistical
models and
thus generate a candidate or a number of
candidates out of it you package the
whole thing into a runtime which you run
as a
as a service
our our
engine is available only as a microsoft
hosted service meaning there's no
there's no local install that you can
run on premises
we think this is a good model to run a
machine translation service
because it scales well and it allows us
to
to produce the quality and performance
that is necessary we couldn't do that
for local installs
our system uses
two
different decoders a
what we call a
linguistically informed statistical
system it uses a parser on the source
language to give us additional
linguistic information that's used in
the statistical process
we don't have that for every single
language for the languages where we
don't have that
we use a pure phrase based
model with a little bit linguistics on
the target side
okay now coming to the meat of the uh
of the presentation here so data sources
um
the web is really a
a huge benefit to any machine
translation vendor the web is an
excellent
resource of data
as you know as a consumer of the web you
can't believe everything you read on the
internet
you that's also true for for training
data that you get so you need to apply
pretty severe
filtering and
and
adjustment of the data that you are
finding on the internet
much better and easier to consume is
existing parallel data
i already mentioned microsoft's own
data
dictionaries phrase books
government data the governments are
pretty active in releasing
releasing their data some of it is
available or a lot of it is available
through tda in fact but there are other
organizations that they do that say the
same thing for instance ldc and elra
also publishing
significant
corpora
and the
the rest is licensed data for instance
from book publishers a
heavily
researched and
somewhat i would say somewhat successful
area is mining
not exactly parallel data
wikipedia is a good
is a good source of that
news
also a good good source of that if you
imagine there's a one news event and two
different news organizations report on
it in
two
two different languages they talk about
the same stuff but it's not a direct
one-to-one translation you can take that
data and learn something
from it
that is that is being used
so
the availability of
parallel data
and most when when i talk about about
data i mean most importantly parallel
data same documents into the two
languages
but that's of course not the only thing
that that is used in an nt system but it
is the important driver for
for
coverage at least
and vocabulary
uh it's not really the only significant
driver for quality overall
so
i give you here the the the growth
over a uh
over one year a little more than one
year
and i will contrast that with the with
the with the actual measured quality
later on
so
here at the conference frequently
mentioned
was blue scoring which is an automatic
score
that
basically automatically calculates the
delta between a human translation and a
machine translation you always need to
give it a reference a human translated
reference
blue scores are not exactly comparable
between different types of engines and
not between languages either
so we use an additional human evaluation
score
where we give a number of uh sentences
to at least four independent evaluators
that tell us how good it is
and we use a ranking between one and
four notice there is no midpoint we want
the
evaluator to choose if it is
well if it is if it is good or bad and
then how good or bad it is
they cannot make no choice so and then
and then we we calculate the average we
um we have we have determined that four
is the minimum number you need to get a
statistically relevant uh
distribution
um so one is bad four is good uh you can
see that for most language pairs the
scores hover somewhere between between
two and three imagine
two 2.5 is
the midpoint as in 2.5 means half of the
sentences are good well are at least
understandable
so we're happy if we if we get above
about
three we are nowhere around
four human translators don't get to four
either human translators are around 3.8
so
let me just overlay uh well let me let
me go back to this here so those are the
uh the the
the blue score quality increases uh
across languages that we have seen
over a period of uh nine months
right we did we did four four
significant updates in these nine months
and those are the scores
um
you see it goes up not particularly uh
drastically and you see there's actually
a huge
difference again the language that is
that is high up here
is not necessarily a lot better than the
language that is down here as i
mentioned blue scores are not comparable
between languages right because blues
blue scores takes world-breaking word
length and things like that into into
account which different languages and
does not
uh really reflect the uh
the the human
perception between languages but
they you can compare them to each other
i mean to itself to a previous version
of itself that that's how i know that
the quality goes up
contrasting that with the data increase
data is the
most important driver of of quality
increases
and
our focus is on of course the
the the base
modeling and
and algorithmic improvements
on the on the decoder itself
and the rest is focused on gathering
data and processing and filtering the
data